we are joined today on the Michael
Knowles show by flex talks the YouTube
star the Dartmouth graduate the troller
of lefties all over the Internet
plus we'll also have Antonia Okafor and
so Rachel to join the panel of
deplorable we'll be talking about the
giant Trump chicken a thirteen million
year old eight and gay seatbelt
I'm Michael Nolt this is the Michael
nose
[Music]
[Music]
our first entry our guest ever fleck is
talk
Austin Fletcher if you haven't seen this
guy he's put up like three videos on the
internet and he's just the biggest thing
on YouTube he's put up 24 videos he has
been at you has been on Tucker Carlson
he's been all over the place let's take
a look we have a little super cut we're
at the March for truth here June 3rd
person square downtown LA we're heading
down to Town Hall we're going to yell
about why we don't like Trump so he
hopefully quits
Kathy Griffin actually spoke for all of
us and took the hit for the entire
planet she didn't speak for me she spoke
for me I thought all of us is free oh no
hey guys it's like us throughout here at
Hollywood Boulevard walk insane
protecting Donald Trump star from these
people trying to deface it I hate Donald
Trump I'm a socialist a true socialist
and he is nothing but a fashion I'm
Roberto gets up why he gets shot because
tapas against everybody who's not in his
class I look at it like anybody does not
like I don't know what topstitch ways
because he's brewing with Kanye with so
you can't really excite oh I wouldn't be
mad about everything everything what do
you think is most to it I think that's
okay well you know like I'm just mad
about everything so Austin man thank you
for coming thank you for having good
welcome to our illustrious studios in
our little cramped closet the broom
closet of the ben shapiro show so the
first question I have to ask why are
conservatives so much better at the
Internet why are we so much better at
YouTube and trolling the left it seems
like we're outpacing them by miles I
agree and you're absolutely right we are
better at the Internet I think it's kind
of coming down to the cultural fight I
think the left and the right are
fighting for the culture right now and I
think we're really doing a better job
online I mean the left kind of
controlling the mainstream media they
can controlling look like movies and
films and TV but we're kind of slowly
taking it back and the next frontier is
the Internet so kind of make sense it's
you're right there's this whole deck
stacked against us we're out here in
Hollywood you know the Hollywood
mainstream media totally stacked against
conservatives but we also have Google
and YouTube were stacked against concern
they've cut conservative revenue they're
going to start censoring the videos
apparently Google is firing people for
putting common sense into a memo but
we're still dominating on like is
YouTube a conservative platform or are
we are we going to need to look for
other places once they shut us down
I think at one point YouTube was a
conservative platform but right now we
need to actually find a different
platform because of the recent another
ADL's doing the censorship of a certain
YouTube profiles so of extremists
extreme that nation extreme yeah and
like I said someone tagged me and one of
the things on Twitter was like hey you
got to watch out man they're trying to
you know stifle our voice I was like
don't tag me in this part I'm sure
they're going to look at whoever they're
talking to about it like don't tag me in
it I think it's the it's the Taliban
beard that's why they're not because of
your conservative views it's got to be
the the beard or siding yeah maybe yeah
one of the problems so you're from
Dartmouth you're clearly smart
conservative guy and you're out here
doing comedy what is it about Dartmouth
Dartmouth produces all of these great
conservatives at dinesh d'souza Laura
Ingraham our buddy Josh riddle and the
young cons guys some Peter Robinson
George rut lore so on and so forth
what's in the water up there um I think
it has a lot to do I mean on campus it's
especially lately it's been very
divisive when it comes to the lepers -
right and I think it's an extreme amount
of leftist like movement left this
classes that says everything is so left
that it makes people that are going to
head to the right head there sooner mmm
so I think when you're up there and you
know Cinco de Mayo the party gets
canceled because they were planning on
serving tacos and they're like okay wait
a minute that's kind of BS and then it
makes people wake up and have like their
you know red pill moments if you will
sooner were you were you always a
conservative I actually wasn't I am only
became conservative in the last couple
years in college I I mean I didn't know
how much I supported Obama because I
didn't actually do anything political at
all but I thought Obama was a good
president I saw him give a speech and he
cried and I'm like this guy cares for
the people you know his whole thing was
pushing changed when I was in college
I'm like yeah change like that's what we
need but realistically I didn't
participate in politics I bear
and headlines and it was until I mean
the campaign's is last year where I
really woke up and saw what was going on
I saw how the left in the mainstream
media is pandering to these people who
don't actually know what's going on and
they just push this idea of oh yeah
you're morally superior if you're moral
you know you'll support Hillary Clinton
and that was the red flag for me because
they're politicizing morality which is
completely inappropriate and it's very
divisive but now it's announced a war
that's that's interesting especially on
the on the Dartmouth front being a
Dartmouth I guess moved you more to the
right do you find that there's any
Dartmouth always had the reputation of
being a more conservative Ivy League
school do you think that is true do you
think the professor's were targeting
conservatives as has happened in a lot
of other schools um
I think when I was there I graduated in
2012 so I think when I first started in
2008 it was pretty okay but then in the
last ten years or so it's really heading
in a direction where there's no more
debate there's no more dialogue and I
think we have been Shapira made a great
point they said ten years ago used to go
do speeches and even have security you
just walk into a speech or liked it or
hated them and you walked out now
they're shutting down the streets
they're destroying campuses flipping
over cars because people want to come
talk so the room for debate has gone
away and with that I think the silent
majority needs to be less silent and I
think we need to kind of take a stand
and show that we're proud to be
conservative show our values are
actually more in line with what a
self-proclaimed
college liberal would say we're not as
bad is you know the old Republicans they
think we are there has been a shift that
I even noticed that we graduated in the
same year in 2012 and I noticed it from
my freshman year to my senior year maybe
it was because it was an election year
when we got there Barack Obama had just
won everybody was jumping for joy and I
except for the five of us Republicans on
campus we get vodka and one of the
freshman dorms that shipped it really
didn't really on mean it's gone I went
back up from my reunion it seems much
more vicious much more tense than it was
a lot of times people will write in from
for the mailbag or whatever and say if
I'm a conservative at college should I
speak my mind or should I hide and get
good
what do you think well there's a fine
line I think the answer used to be kind
of hide and get good grades because get
the grade that's going to help and
whatever but now I think I'm starting a
movement myself I've some people who are
going to go out to college campuses this
fall and start interviewing protesters
and a vented liberal in a liberal event
at their local colleges and interview
the people and just have a discussion
and then send me the footage and then
I'm going to chop it up and make like a
you know best of the fans and [ __ ]
talks so I'm trying to take back the
college's I think that's the next
frontier I think people are being
indoctrinated there's no better word
than that and we need to get in the
faces of the Liberals non-violently and
say what are you doing here why do you
disagree with Trump where you screw this
policy and ask questions where people
need to explain themselves because we
need to stop the police ation of
morality it's not it's not where the
games headed so what what is the moment
what is the flex on the road to Damascus
you're at Dartmouth you're up there in
Hanover is there some big event that
happens this is just you're reading
certain things you're talking to certain
people or you're just getting
progressively disgusted by the lefties
so the combination of yet getting
constantly disgusted by the left all
these social justice warriors and
everything they're pushing is just so
soft like what would happen to toughness
and grit that's what America was all
about a few years ago that's what my
grandparents came here they were tough
and my grandma came here and she worked
in the factory so dresses in took care
of her family and saved all the money
she could to help you know her daughter
which is my mom and then it keeps you
know those values need to be still and
they're not and I think it's just like
the universities have become this safe
space and it's too safe it's too soft
and it's about time we take it back on
this is a little bit of a tangential
point but you're also of Italian descent
as I am the Italians tend to trend
Republican of other immigrant groups
Italians tend to be quite Republican my
family on the Italian side is because of
that toughness that I don't know how to
put it as you know c'est quoi
they tend to vote Republican they're all
tougher what is it about the Italian
culture
does that it's a I think yes the
toughness is just they be forever me at
least my mom came from a family where
they came from nothing and they came
from Italy with a few dollars in their
pocket they got in a boat they came here
dropped out of high school and just
worked and she remembers the lessons she
learned for her parents I think it's the
Italians have it's a good well toughness
they really they really appreciate
toughness I really appreciate grit and
hard work and not making excuses and
that's where my wooden spoon microphone
comes from I had the wooden spoon I'm
sorry about this you have to serve for
those who haven't seen it Austin's
microphone is a wooden spoon with a tape
recorder taped to it so yeah what
brought that idea so that's kind of just
bringing the wooden spoon back to these
we left this because I just growing up
my misbehaves my mom would pull the
spoon out and blacken up in it you know
calm down and I listened I don't want to
hit the wooden spoon and now these
protesters mostly millenials are out in
the streets having a big temper tantrum
and it's because no one gave them the
wooden spoon no one gave them tough
structural upbringing and now they you
know they were they're calling for
socialism they want it their way they
want everyone to be you know equal
outcome and it's not it's not where it's
headed do you think we talked about this
a little bit yesterday Millennials have
this reputation of being snowflakes of
being coddled their helicopter parented
there they haven't been exposed to the
realities of the world do you think
that's fair it's a fair criticism of
them they also have a lot of student
debt they've also got a ton of divorced
parents
they've also they're going to inherit a
lot of big national debt do we're being
too hard on Millennials or is it just a
fact of life and we got to straighten
them out I think I think the millennial
group is still forming imagine it being
like clay and we're still deciding who
these people are going to become what
the cult is going to be what the main
message of this generation is going to
be so I think we're at a point now where
we can kind of decide you know who the
Millennials are in a few years from now
right now they're they color coming
across as a little soft a little
entitled they're more educated than ever
but they're sitting in student loan debt
with no job a lot of them live at home
they're trying to tell us how the
country should run how the government
should be run how
onam you should be run it's kind of like
just because you're educated and took a
class about this doesn't mean that you
should be in charge like there's a
system here and it involves being tough
it involves you know failing and getting
back up and going again and that's what
these people wax so very credential but
just because they took a class doesn't
mean they're educated at all I mean
education is decayed a lot I don't know
that these people they might have higher
SAT scores but I don't know that they
are more educated than a class from the
1940s or 5000 Thalia great but they're
more entitled than ever
which is a huge issue because I mean
here's back not everyone went to college
you know
so either you know graduate high schools
you do good enough in high school and
care about certain stuff you go to
college cool get a job if you don't get
in the workforce now everyone goes to
college everyone thinks oh I go to
college dollars a million dollars of
debt and it's for what to party for four
years and drink a bunch of beer I would
say a quarter maybe there's a lot of con
for you it was great um but you know
here we are these people now are I don't
know why why should we give them
credibility why should they be in charge
of anything I don't really don't get it
well so you you're at dorm if you
graduate Dartmouth as is your Ivy League
birthright you immediately go to Wall
Street just like you know I when I
graduated they had I got three emails
from Yale's employment office or office
of God knows life and the first one said
a career panel about finance and the
other one said a career panel in the law
and then the third one said alternative
career path sooo that you can do and
then you have to so you go down to Wall
Street what makes you go down there so
growing up I had a strict upbringing and
my mom had a plan for us she told all
the kids you know go to the college get
a good job go move out of the house and
just make something make something with
yourself so I knew that was the like my
goal at the time so I got internships I
really built up my resume I played
football so I reached out to some alumni
football players and God hooked up with
an internship which has led to a
full-time job and that was basically
just following my parents pact which I
was so happy I did because it was a
great experience I learned about waking
up at 5:00 in the morning every day I
learned about staying late until you
know you're the last one 100
are we over it over yeah and we're
working on Wall Street exactly and then
they make you go out for drinks with
people and you can't leave until
everyone's done so you know you're out
till 2:00 3:00 in the morning for this
damn drinks frustrate or worse and he's
come back to work like three hours later
sometimes I went straight to work from
like you know hosting clients or
whatever so I learned a lot though and
then from there I learned what I didn't
want to do and I learned that I wanted
to create my own content I want to
create my own brand and just get out
there and create something I could
affect people in a bigger way so you've
got a career ahead of you you're on Wall
Street Dartmouth graduate king in the
world guaranteed to make a lot of money
have a good life and then you decide to
make the very wise decision to throw all
of it away to go piss off lefties at
Airport and on the internet I'm not
being facetious I think it was a great
decision what if you the guts to do that
um I was sitting in I was sitting in the
my promotion meeting I was going to get
promoted to associate they were really
happy and I said actually I only give
you guys a two weeks notice next week
when my contract was up I'm plenty of
moving to California and everyone
laughed they thought it was hilarious
and then I'm like no seriously I am as
people said you're making the worst
mistake of your life you can't do this
no one has a job right now like 10,000
people applied for 35 spots you got one
and you're leaving and I was like so
Luke California I bought a 1999 sl500
convertible oh nice really cool I drove
that around for a little bit and then
yeah and then after a couple years of
you know making comedy before this idea
I wasn't huge into politics until this
past election and I'm so happy I I
became passionate about it it's my
favorite thing in the world right now it
is amazing you leave your Wall Street
job to go do comedy in Hollywood but not
just to do comedy in Hollywood to do
comedy as a conservative Vietnam is a
really niche perhaps your following here
but it's you know you don't you don't
look like a banker you don't you clearly
and this brings me to my other question
why are these people talking to you why
do these guys at these protests allow
you to humiliate them on video well I
think a lot of the conservative
interviewers like Jesse Watters and
those types they'll come actually with
this suit and the microphone and the you
know production crew and they're hitting
you with questions and everyone kind of
just clams up and they do
a lot of post-production sound effects
and they cut to a you know Jack
Nicholson clip we go what are you
talking about and then they're like this
guy roasted but I think that there's
more to it if we can actually hear these
people out then we can decide really if
they make sense so I sneak up on them
you know wearing clothes like they were
just just stuff I like to wear but I
have my spoon microphone I look like an
idiot
I have like this dumb fat face and a
beard so they just think I'm a nobody
I go up to UM hey what are you doing
here my questions are really easy what
are you doing here who did you vote for
what is your sign say no because oh I'm
here because Donald Trump's worse than
Hitler he's going to kill all the Jews
all right keep going like that happened
last video so someone was saying I was
like I'll take hold you know very cool
very cool and what else about this this
and this and they just open up to me for
some reason well you know you don't look
like a smart conservative and then you
are a smart conservative and it catches
them off guard a lot of great
politicians talk about this they talk
about playing dumber than their mark
Bill Clinton does at george w bush does
it do you think that is
that is the way to engage lefties you'd
play it you don't try to slam them you
know yeah I think 100% I think that's
what Trump does to every because people
look at Trump and you look at trumping
either one or two ways either think he's
a brilliant you know mastermind savant
or you think he's some real estate idiot
who's in charge of the country I can't
believe it was just coincidentally
succeeded in like a whole different
industry at the top of all you know
exactly and if you look at him like he's
so if you're here and you look at him
like he's dumb he knows that and he
embraces that kind of ingrate embraces
his like you know his Queens New York
and he lets you think that because now
we located him down like this he's
really up here making moves you know and
he and he has your reaction to him
planned for he knows what you're going
to think about all the stuff he does and
he's like a step ahead it's before DHS
they talk about right here you're an
adherent of the forty chess basic yeah
but I don't think the guy's an idiot I
think it is really hard to imagine that
a guy would succeed in television real
estate casinos and he has succeeded in
all of them he's had bad deals he's had
things go bankrupt and then obviously
politics he comes in his first race ever
he beats 16 of the most prominent
politicians in the country and then
takes out the Clintons it's hard to
imagine that guys
I mean do you do you think conservatism
is ascendant right now do you think in
the age of Trump
we're just winning winning we're getting
sick and tired of winning or do you
think you know some of the never Trump
people say it really it's a Pyrrhic
victory we are losing the culture we're
becoming too much like the left do you
think we're winning do you think we're
losing as Trump and net positive or net
negative I think right now it's that
positive at the way I watch the news now
which is it's actually been working out
i watch the mainstream news like CNN for
example and I watch it backwards so I'll
see the men you know the leaking of
omena Ford's house got rated you know a
month ago and that gets leaked I see
that as okay so big news is coming for
the right and that's their pre-emptive
thing to kind of like eat up the news
cycle when it's happening that's an
interesting theory and it not probably
not far from the truth I would not put
it past them at all I mean the lies that
have been published New York Times just
got caught in this big climate change
report line their whole report was
inaccurate CNN one story after another
Washington Post same thing they're
clearly they've become activists if ever
they weren't activists against the
Republican Party wouldn't be surprised
at all I think we've got to try to as
I'm going to try your strategy yeah it
works yeah that so you're you're
reaching out to these college kids do
you think we're talking about post
Millennials really we're not talking
about 28 29 year olds which I met these
kids were in college now if we were the
Obama generation do you think there's a
chance that the dominant culture among
these young people the RET not dominant
but the subversive and cool culture is
finally on the right are we finally
seeing that or are we getting ourselves
yeah I absolutely believe that I think
the strongest movements are kind of
these cult followings and these like you
know very niche specific and that's
right what we're falling into here I
think the younger generation is
generation Z right they're more
conservative than ever and they don't
like getting their news from TV they
like to go online into research they
like the reddit's and 4chan and all that
kind of stuff so I think these people
aren't going to just take what's dead to
them and say oh like that's what I
believe
grade Trump's that they're actually they
desire the truth and the ways of the old
Republicans where it's kind of in your
face America guns all these things
that's getting adjusted and the parties
are rebranding the Democrats aren't
doing a good job of that they keep
pushing Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
and Clinton and Hillary Clinton so bad
but the the right is rebranding and the
new young conservative movement is to
take pride in knowing the facts they
love knowing the facts but then they can
go debate anybody and say it pretty much
however they want if they're based in
truth and they're slowly fighting back
and taking back the culture and I think
we're coming into a really cool
nonviolent war here that's going to be
exciting and therefore they're fighting
the sentimental PC hogwash that we've
been imbued with for decade upon decade
it is an exciting time almost as
exciting as bringing on the panel of
deplorable we've got we're very lucky
today we've got so raychel and Antonia
Okafor and flex is going to stick around
so you know we've got all of these
internet e people here I've got to ask
all of us in our political lives every
person here is sort of a product of the
internet that was our entrance into
politics so though is it because the
internet is a whole rig leans right or
is it because everything else leans left
or some combination oh well you know the
conversation is about of I've got the
email for a conservative culture not
like conservative in our cultural you
got one really and no but in terms of
the leaning right or leaning left it's
it's a foundation of leftism that the
right is using and trying to try and
trying to even else if I could like let
me just kind of like Jesus from the lens
of my own experience I don't want to
make this about me and make it sound a
self-absorbed but as I'm examining it I
know there's a leftist foundation
because when it comes to like people
like need they don't want people to see
people like me at all
that's right because my work isn't right
I'm not trying to make up I'm not trying
to make Lester's angry I usually make
them laugh and the leftist can't have
that you make me laughed and leftists I
getting confused in our yeah I'm sorry
the world
it's absurd and they teach you to make
jokes other so but the thing is what
they'll do is that they'll try to mask
my work to make it look uninteresting
innocent roles after me because trolls
equals views they don't want my views to
go up and sometimes when the trolls come
they end up reconsidering what it is
that they thought so they can't have
that either so basically all that to say
is when you get to your question of the
lien writers and lean left no it's not
elected foundational YouTube this is
their platform this is their foundation
now we're making you sub and I think
that kind of has to stop and you know
speaking I've lived under the bridge for
a very long time and I can't say well
the Internet in these platforms might be
left those trolls definitely lean right
there is no question about that
Antonia do you think this right wing
online activism the the laughs and the
serious commentary and the fact and all
of that does it translate into real
political results or are we all just
babbling into the air yeah no I
definitely think that it has results
actually I think that really like I said
like you said I started out with the
internet coach they're like being able
to spread my message that way and I
think because people just like he was
saying like so just said that because
they when they do see people like me and
they're like oh my gosh that's not what
I think of the traditional conservative
well now they're they're stereotypes
have changed and really basically their
whole their whole and a shin has changed
because the left have made it so much
about race and sex and gender so I think
yeah the more and that's why we don't
see people like us because it really is
changing people's minds and making
people I mean that's what changed me I
saw someone else who was a black
conservative I was like whoa they exist
and then I was like okay well I guess I
could come out of closet now so yeah I
think it does because that's just it
smashes this whole vision that we've
been presented with I don't think
anybody on the screen right now is what
people think of when they think of the
young Republican maybe even you know my
jackets a little too loud usually the
Brooks Brothers buttoned up the hair
parted all of that that and also you've
actually had some very real results in
in your activism on guns and and
obviously you know we were talked about
last week the number of black women and
killer who were who are purchasing guns
and getting permits is way up so we're
at least with you we're seeing real
results when you have mugs like the
three of us probably not as effective
but at least the antónio before it
Michael you need to give yourself credit
I mean we went to Yale and you are still
a concern you know I think it's a big in
yourself a lot mark thank you the thing
that Yale can do is either make you into
a kind of left-wing automaton or it
makes you such a reactionary that you go
completely in the other direction all
right you know on that I have to address
all you cheapskates out there because
you cheapskates who want to keep
watching this panel of deplorable to
discuss all the news of the day and get
the mailbag even later on you can't do
it unless you go to daily wired.com
right now and subscribe it's $10 a month
$100 a year and you get everything you
get my show you get the andrew Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show all
three of which are in the top 25 on news
and politics in the entire world go
there right now don't be a cheapskate
and you get all the rest daily wire duck
forget about all of this internet news
this culture there's politics we need to
talk about the really important issues
according to the Washington Post some
idiot assembled a giant inflatable
chicken with golden Donald Trump air
outside at the White House on Wednesday
do you get it because Donald Trump is a
chicken do you get it isn't it so funny
Austin President Obama's strategy in
Libya was called leading from behind his
strategy on North Korea was called
strategic patience and yet they're
accusing our side of being chicken is
are they just projecting were they
getting this from I think yeah
definitely partially projecting but
anything that guy does they have to hate
so if he comes out and said you know
everyone's great and I love the left I
love the right and all people are equal
they're getting mad about it kim
jeong-hoon comes out and threatens to
the nuke us or the new guam where one of
our provinces what's wrong with what he
said he took a strong stance we haven't
done in the past and now it's you know
he's being offensive he's being
irrational the guy can't get it right
that's absolutely whatever he does they
have to do the opposite I guess and on
this on this kind of psychobabble things
oh the Democrats called Bush a Chicken
Hawk they called same thing about Dick
Cheney they said that george w bush was
had daddy issues and was trying to
resolve what his father didn't resolve
it's all of this psychobabble why do
they love making these insinuations
instead of talking about rebuilt issues
and real policies well if we're going to
use the term psychobabble let's let's
toss in the word projection because
that's what they're doing they're
projecting their own disposition onto
somebody else if they want to call a
Donald Trump a chicken man have you guys
seen that that viral video man where it
has this cat-like back and this little
mouse around right I imagine it's at
your DC notifier I do Jeff fountain bad
mouse around just playing with it and
this chicken comes out of nowhere man 2x
catches up this mouse just start bashing
it on the farm and it just runs off with
his mouth now if you're going to call
Donald Trump a chicken that's what it's
like it's just like Hillary the cat like
fat around it is take you guys are good
at to fight feeding right I'm going to
be the next
if I only be good for this give me a
double chop that you just coasted no
mine outwitted executed a Marshall we
need to make a no you need to animate
that immediately we need to get that
I'll do you exactly by the way Michael
now Antonia we're lucky that we have
Antonia here because your reputation and
your motives are constantly impugned to
people in seaweed all sorts of
psychobabble on you how do you respond
to those people how do you do you
respond to those accusations or do you
just ignore them and move on and keep
doing what you're doing
oh no yeah I completely I always did
ignore because I'm better than everybody
no way I don't lose it was certainly
true I definitely talk to them and I
definitely respond I try through
depending on my mood actually like have
a coherent conversation that's not just
what you saw back or you know something
like but mostly dreams you don't know
[ __ ] up
I need my graduate degree I know I don't
it really just blown student loan money
that I'm going to have to pay back later
but really when I do comes out to it I
tell them especially like when it comes
to the rate issue they'll be like oh
you're a token oh you're an energy I'm
doing something alright like oh you're
using you you know basically they're
telling me that because I'm a black
person another white person is telling
me as a black person that because I am a
black person that's the only like
credibility that I have in order to
succeed and then yet they're like oh
well you know what we really need like
affirmative action and we need all these
different things to collect just don't
understand this culture that does not
think that black people are able to
actually have thoughts outside of being
controlled by somebody that's right you
only have my brain I only have brains in
parrot what everybody else is saying but
if you think for yourself then you're
totally brain-dead you're a puppet
you're being used and of course mix
totally think yourself and it's not
before exactly and now I never figure
yourself met me thinking just like you
need he has that look that beard is
that's good thank you
it's going to get them on that YouTube
watch list
now KLM the Dutch airline has has
recently gotten into the news because
they tweeted out a photo for Pride Month
it was three rainbow seatbelts in a row
and they had one where was the nail
buckle and the female buckle and then
they had one reverse mail button on the
mail buckle now when were as a female
buck on the female buckle and the tweet
read it doesn't matter who you click
with happy Pride Amsterdam now there is
one issue with this image that only one
of them clicks only male and female
actually click now so is this the
stupidest tweet of all time or is this
4d chest you know we are talking about
KLM on the on the show today
maybe they're just mastermind probably
not allowed nature itself dictate that
you can't connect poles to poles and
hold the whole man better but I'm gonna
have to end on out thank you that is a
very accurate analysis I've heard of
this you know coming well if you talk
about this is Twilight Zone type stuff
and it's a just stitches by the laws of
nature that doesn't work is like this is
pride that priding all work if you
autumn man I don't even know how to
respond to that that's just funny maybe
it was really maybe it was anti gay
marriage you're saying it doesn't matter
whom you click with it just has to click
it has to click or it's an abomination
maybe that's what its gonna donate
esoteric you can't you can't naturally
make that click that it's like what you
gonna hold that together with duct tape
that does that doesn't work it doesn't
matter if you click with and if it
doesn't click roll it up and duct tape
Antonia why is an airline tweeting about
sex
why do I care I've flown KLM it's fine
why do we care what KLM thinks about
homosexuality or Pride Month or whatever
well why is Teen Vogue writing articles
about how you can have anal sex I mean
we cancel my submissions I haven't read
the article well I mean ups I'm telling
it was this day and age that anything
goes apparently I mean yeah but the
funny thing too is that effort that's
like aw man that social media intern is
totally like not good
any full credit yes I can but then I was
like but then they had the picture with
it it was just just the text it would've
been like a social media intern but then
they actually put thought into it had a
picture you know displayed it and made
it a campaign they probably had them
anything about they probably had seven
so so I'm just like yeah I'm not flying
with that airline obviously they can't
even put those two things together and
people were thinking it was the been
essentially click and then they say it
in the actual text back when I read it I
wonder what the safety demonstration
looks like excuse me I'll show you how
it works right now
Austin you make leftists say stupid
things on video but ok elem is showing
us that leftists will just say stupid
things themselves completely unprovoked
is there a place for us in this world or
heads up here if they transcended parity
um I think there is a place for us I
think this is a perfect opportunity and
I've realized too in the last especially
the last year if you're going to put
something on the internet it better be
what you really believe because the
trolls are going to tear it apart so
once I saw this come up I was like all
right here comes and sure enough all the
Conservatives went right after it and
I'm sure Kaelyn will be out with like a
you know some you know an amendment to
it those will come out with some some
sort of a retraction down the road
they'll have to because anything you put
out right now if it doesn't line up with
certain groups will play their own game
at it you will just the trolls will tear
it up absolutely now another important
story there has been a discovery of a
thirteen million year old ape skull that
shows what human ancestors may have
looked like question goes to you Austin
why was it necessary for God to put this
fake skull on earth to test our fate why
did he have to do this yeah it's a great
question it's just a perfect opportunity
to continue to be faithful though we
have to ignore this we have to ignore
science of selectively of course okay
and we have to kind of you know decide
what we believe what we don't believe I
don't believe that well now
you sound like the left because we need
some science but we need to selectively
ignore science you know the same people
who tell us that men are really women if
they say they're women but not if they
don't say they're women they are they
accuse us conservatives of denying
science Antonio do you think there is a
conflict between faith and science well
first of all I remember physically bed
suppose so that he was going to identify
as a woman so there would be half an
equal representation of genders and with
pain all the best I repeat about it
later I know he's lying science tonight
is getting very confusing I really think
of it actually Leslie used to go Bob
yeah so so faith in science I mean for
me and I'm a woman of faith and I
definitely believe that I've I think all
of the stuff that's happening is really
just showing it's just backing up our
faith I mean I'm a Christian so I still
believe though as that God has has had a
plan for people part of his plan
amperage it is unscientific uncovering
whether it's giving other than our
intelligent designer right yeah
absolutely
a lot of people they'll say well do you
believe in Genesis or do you believe in
the Big Bang and people forget because
not only are they science deniers but
their history deniers that it was a
Catholic priest who discovered the Big
Bang was George lumetri who discovered
it and there is the more that we learn
about science the more light that's been
shown on our faith it seems to me so
what do you think are you a science
denier a god denier or both I bet you're
both okay I'm a denier neither I so you
love it you know the things that they
they claim to you know you know come up
with good science you know these are all
discoveries that's all you can really do
with science is discovering the things
that they get serviced or things that
the Bible has already talked about in
order to talk about even the Big Bang
right or when they're talking about how
the universe is expanding you know so
they say that the universe is
contracting indicated universe is
expanding not only expanding its
speeding up well the Bible already told
us that the Lord spread out the heavens
like a tent that has to start with a
compression point and open up in terms
of the age skull um I don't know how
they tie that to us if they want to go
ahead and see themselves descendants of
H going there you know be my gift
instead of Joe Biden
rather a joke I saw that facial
structure seems to add up somehow but I
guess they're trying to put a date on it
and the thing is if you read the Bible
the Bible lets you know quite clearly
that there was an earth before the
Genesis account I have to read the thing
we don't know reading stuff and we don't
do that so much anymore most at most
I'll read a texture to ok panel thank
you so much for being here
we have so raychel Antonio Okafor and
flex talks now it is time for the
mailbag we have got a lot of mailbag
question today so we are going to fly
through these the first one comes from
Johnny dear MK ULTRA thank you very nice
should a conservative walk through a
hyper leftist school unseen to survive
or should they try to explain their
beliefs to their peers austin i guess we
talked about that a little bit i take a
different view then i think most people
i think a lot of people say put your
head down get the good grades get out of
here i personally am convinced at least
on one occasion
my grades were hurt at yale because of
my views only on one occasion though
which says a lot about the school i did
not do that i was very open about my
politics i was the head of every
conservative republican thing i trolled
every lefty that i saw you know we did
occupy occupy new haven we did all these
things and i've enjoyed it same thing in
hollywood in since i've been you know as
an actor in new york and theater film TV
out here as well and i was always open
about my politics has it hurt me did it
hurt me at yale academically or socially
did it hurt me in show business maybe it
has I never wanted to hide my own views
I don't think it's worth it's worth
doing that I don't think that you should
be denying what you think but that said
there are huge risks to it so you've got
to really weigh it out there risks to
both sides and I don't think there's an
easy answer on it but what I would do is
be honest about about your point of view
next question from Joe Grandmaster
Noel's thank you a lot of talk over this
NASA planetary defender position is
there any chance that a certain
best-selling author ivy-league-educated
Sicilian provocateur will be applying
just show them the frame tweet the
thought of you being the only
line of defense between me and the
threat of alien annihilation makes me
truly believe in Trump's America looking
forward to the sequel I am convinced I
am the planetary protector I'm convinced
I'm neo in the matrix
ever since my blank book became the
number one bestseller I now know this
isn't the real world this is only a
simulation so maybe I'm Keanu Reeves I'm
glad that I got the position didn't even
have to apply next question from
Allister hi I'm Michael yay finally a
podcast so happy for you I'm looking for
the most comprehensive definition of
what conservatism is would it be fair to
say that the most comprehensive guide
would be the entirety of the Federalist
Papers would there need to be anything
added to that or does the Federalist
Papers delve outside the scope of what
conservatism is I I'm happy to give a
definition I think conservatism evades
definition though in my view it would be
three things ordered Liberty human
dignity and a skepticism of ideology so
I love the Federalists everyone should
read the Federalist cover-to-cover if
you're in this country you should have
read the Federalist there are also other
people to read Edmund Burke Russell Kirk
conscience of a conservative Bill
Buckley all of those great writers who
contributed Tocqueville also I think
people ought to read Michael Oakshott
gave a definition of ideology in the
essay rationalism and politics it was so
influential to my political view that I
memorized it he defines ideology is the
formalized abridgement of the supposed
substratum of rational truth contained
in the tradition and that's why the
rationalist always get a bunch of
cockamamie ideas and ignore reality in
front of them a lot of times college
professors seem to be saying who cares
if it works in practice does it work in
theory and so I recommend reading those
guys and always having a healthy
skepticism of ideology of check lists of
political political tests one way or the
other
and taking it as a whole institutions
the institutions of the west and the
ideas that have guided them and that
have come out of them next question from
Silas this is a much more serious
question than that
dear mr. knowledge I meant Knowles well
it's the same thing I guess I think
you're right hail to you sir trolls a
lot right
man to comment on Clavin beater of
Shapiro in a game of chance both true I
will ask you one more time can you
confirm or deny that Andrew Clavin the
master of the multiverse and slayer of
PC dragons is an extraterrestrial
shapeshifter Silas come on man can I can
I confirm or deny the fish swim or that
birds fly use your my open your eyes man
wake up sheeple next question comes from
rosemary one please distinguish Sicilian
from Italian yes it matters about seven
shades of color is the difference and
the second question is please expand on
your reversion to Christianity I'm happy
to do that we talked a little bit about
this last week the the smart I was in
atheist agnostic practical atheist from
13 to 20 21 22 and one thing that was
strange is everyone at Yale was an
atheist but the smartest people at Yale
were Christian particularly Catholic or
Eastern Orthodox in in my experience and
so I started to contemplate the
arguments for God I think a lot of
people come to religion and Christianity
in particular because of a religious
experience a numinous experience of some
sort ineffable it wasn't that way for me
primarily that came later I consider the
arguments for God they're about a dozen
good ones and I was just convinced I
thought the arguments for God were
better than the arguments against God in
particularly in particular rather the
ontological argument which was formed by
st. Anselm of Canterbury and then later
reformulated by liveness and girdle and
the one that got me was the modal
ontological argument which was put forth
by Alvin Plantinga
a Calvinist out of Notre Dame the
argument I'm not doing it justice but
the simple argument of this God is the
maximally great being that's the
definition of God he has all the great
making characteristics none of the
corrupting characteristics it is better
to exist than not to exist therefore God
must exist there it's much more elegant
when you read it but that's the gist of
the argument it convinces no one but it
did convinced me and I think I think he
has Lois - I think it convinced him and
after that the ineffable experience has
come particularly coincidences the
Christian view of the world is semiotic
it's very symbolic and and then I I
found the church coincidentally st.
Michael's Church in New York where
father George wrote lose the past
and I recommend reading him as well and
and that might bring you to a river
conversion - next question from tad hey
I'm ki listen to your defense of
Christianity and Catholicism episode 4
with admiration I have to wonder if
you're more Catholic than the current
Pope
I am I don't think I'm more Catholic
than the Pope but I do understand where
you're coming from the Pope has been
saying some things that have raised
eyebrows you know there have been plenty
of bad Pope's generally speaking dante
put some of them in hell and the pope
there's a confusion over papal
infallibility the Pope is is fallible
except when he's infallible and by some
counts the Pope has only invoked
infallibility speaking ex cathedra seven
times ten or eleven times so perhaps the
Lord gives us bad Pope's not that I'm
calling Francis a bad vote but perhaps
he gives us bad Pope's to show us that
they're fallible except when they're
infallible Mary a letter from Marie dear
Michael loves the riveting read on
reasons to vote for Democrat you for
reading it if on the coffee table for
anyone who wants to be enlightened my
super serious question is does the
Donald let you borrow his tanner or do
you glow naturally no I
my mother was Sicilian though which does
does explain why I look like I was on
the face of the Sun next question from
Wayne I'm feeling trans Michael Knowles
go see a doctor immediately run do not
walk to the hospital question from
Jackson Michael I've been following
roaming millennial for a while now and I
was not only surprised but very happy to
see you bring her on your show can you
tell us why you chose roaming for your
panel of deplorable z-- and can you tell
us if you plan on bringing her on for a
while I'm so glad you asked this
question you know I am getting married
to my wonderful fiance sweet little
ELISA soon and so I've been bringing
roaming on as a sort of audition for
when we do finally form our right-wing
apocalyptic polygamous cult and she
could be a sister wife so that that's
been I'm really glad you asked I think
there's been some confusion about it
that is the whole mailbag and that takes
up all of my time with flex talks flek
us thank you so much for being here it's
been great to talk to you come back I
guess is the end of this week so come
back on Monday and we'll do it all again
[Music]